we are very excited about our next guest
she is actress
deborah ayorende she stars as lucky
emory in the upcoming her name is lucky
the upcoming amazon original horror
series it's called them
ayurende has appeared in films like you
might have seen her in girls trip or how
about harriet
and the marvel netflix series luke cage
now them is about a black family that
moves from the jim crow south to an
all-white los angeles neighborhood
during the great migration in the 1950s
the family's new home becomes a target
of threats and violence from the
neighbors
along with supernatural forces here's a
look
she's looking right at you can't you see
her
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't go down into the basement then
we'll be available to stream on friday
on amazon
prime video deborah irende joins us now
first on cbs this morning welcome to you
deborah
i was so excited to talk to you because
i've seen the first three episodes i'm
going to talk about that in just a
second
but my son and daughter texted me about
an hour ago and said that there was an
earthquake
in los angeles did you by chance feel
anything
yes i did and i thought i was crazy at
first and then
i found out i wasn't so yes i felt it i
felt
it yeah well registered a four but it
you know which sounds very
small but they said that it was you
could really feel it that it was a
little frightening did it scare you too
everything yes it did everything i mean
you never get used to earthquakes so
everything was shaking around me so yeah
it was definitely
okay i'm glad you're okay i'm glad
everybody's okay
but boy oh boy let's talk about your
series because this is the thing deborah
imagine me
watching this i didn't know anything
about it so when i saw the title them
i thought it was going to be about
aliens and creatures and when i started
watching it i had to make a shift very
quickly as to what was happening on the
screen because
this is the thing it's so beautifully
done but it's also so
heartbreaking to watch it it still is
still sitting with me
and i watched it on saturday and i'm
still sort of rattled by it
so i want to know what it was like for
you to play this character
did it get into your bones yes it did
you know um playing lucky was honestly a
blessing because
she allowed me to uncover a lot of
buried emotions and feelings that i had
that i didn't even realize i had
from just experiencing a lot of um you
know the racism the sexism the
microaggressions the macroaggressions is
over time
you just kind of bury it and you just
show up
and you show up and you show up and you
know lucky required that i
uncover all of that and um
used that to to speak life to her story
and so it was just it was a it was a
difficult blessing yeah hey that's a
good way to put it because i'm thinking
at the end of the day what a great
character to play because
she's a loving wife a mother you know
she's she has
good friends but she also is dealing
with these neighbors who clearly don't
want you there
and so she has some so many moments
where she's like oh not today
i'm not taking this today so what what a
great character for you to play as well
exactly and you know it just shows i
think
you mentioned a beautiful thing about
the fact that the black
love you know the love between lucky and
henry
and the love they have for their
children is a huge part
of the story as well and
it just i mean just to play
a character that is so layered that is
so
it just resonates with who i am as a
woman
as a black woman it was just such a
blessing
and let's let's talk about horror too
being an effective use
to tell talk about racism because i
never thought about this
your home is supposed to be your
sanctuary your safe place
but also becomes a very menacing place
too
right i think um so two things one
i mean racism is horrifying oftentimes
yeah
yeah and i think we speak to that but
also
um i think you know having
our home be also ground zero for a lot
of the
um evil that happens it speaks to
how the experiences can kind of sneak in
on the inside and affect
you know the family unit you have to
think a lot of these people that were
going through
this at this level at that time were
experiencing all these things and still
had to parent
and still had to you know be a good
spouse or
just live and so um
[Music]
having horribly the way we explore this
story
it just makes it it just it it makes
sense
it makes sense it makes sense i've read
too that you
you experienced as yourself as a little
girl being the other i love the title by
the way them because them could also
apply
from the black family's point of view
talking about the white neighbors
who were really horrible to them and
then from the
white neighbors looking at the black
family who they said you know
we really don't want you here but i read
as a little girl that you also
experienced being the other two so i
would imagine that that would trigger
some things for you as well yeah i
definitely did
um how are you the other debra you know
being
nigerian and coming we so my family and
i we moved from london
to the bay area when i was very young
and um
i remember when i first went to the
school i was put in
um i i had a thick british accent still
um durian i'm dark skinned i didn't look
like any other kids i didn't sound like
any of the kids i was already
really shy um so i just
it was terrifying for me and i would eat
lunch in the bathroom every day
i would fake stomach aches so my mom
completely home from school
early um until she caught into my game
and moved me to a school
nearer to the house i feel more
comfortable but it was a really hard
experience
i didn't feel i didn't feel i felt like
a fish out of water
and so just the experience of being them
you don't have to look very far in our
world to see that people are really
fighting
to not be mean at other you know and the
things that they will do just to not be
seen as them
it's crazy and so i've since learned to
embrace what makes me unique and what
makes me different
but i'm as a kid all you want to do is
fit in
all you want to do you know as a means
to not be bullied you want to fit in so
it was really really hard yeah hey hey
deborah it's tony to copel uh while we
talk about all these things that have
been difficult there's one
scene that we haven't seen yet it's not
on the four episodes available to us
that you describe as literally the
hardest thing i've had to do
to date the hardest thing what can you
tell us about it
um so so yes it comes
in the middle of the the season and
um it it required
every single bit of me and then some
because i wanted to make sure
that i played it as authentically as
possible
because i wanted anyone who had
experienced even a fraction of what
lucky experiences
in that scene to feel seen to feel heard
to feel believed
but it stays with me still to this day
it stays with me
and i just i just really really hope
that it
that someone who sees it they're set
free in some separate way
so whoa deborah now i really am very
intrigued because listen of the three
episodes i've seen
i've seen some things that just i don't
know just sort of
took me out i have to say so i can't
imagine we're going to see something
that's even worse than what i've seen so
far that's a great tease
and you should know over two and a half
million people tony was telling me i've
already looked at the trailer so there's
interest
it's hard to watch but i think people
should watch it it's very very well done
thank you deborah you're great in it
thank you thank you very much